so apparently Amazon can't figure out
how to bring our favorite TV show back
they've owned MGM for months now and
they still can't figure out what to do
with Stargate so we actually did a live
video Sunday and we figured it out
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so on Sunday we did a video where we
pretended Amazon chose not to make the
rings of power and instead we spent a
billion dollars for them we figured out
a budget for each one and we spent just
over a billion dollars in the end
because I insist on making Space Balls
too we actually made
in the end because I insist on making
Spaceballs 2 the search for money and we
actually spent a little bit over budget
1.1 billion but uh what's 100 million
dollars between friends now one of my
American friends Young Harris in this
case came up with an amazing idea and
something that I've been thinking about
ever since then I'm going to talk about
in this video but obviously it wasn't
the only Stargate project we thought
about I said I wanted to do a big Grand
Sci-Fi show maybe something based aboard
a BC 305 you know a new ship out of
space dock sort of thing I thought that
would be pretty wicked I also suggested
that I would love to see a prequel
series now if you are a regular
sidetracker you'll know I hate prequels
I think they're rubbish I think they
peel over Canon and every Star Trek
prequel makes me want to cry
um even strange new worlds that I love I
would much prefer it was just that show
but like set in a different time and not
set aboard the Enterprise there are so
many threads of story from sg1 SG
Atlantis and SG universe that lead back
to the Ancients we could see stories
that lead back to things that we already
know happen and give them depth now I
argue that I ordered 100 million dollars
to make this series because I only I
don't want this to be like seven seasons
I think 10 episodes you know they're
making a game a different story each
week that sort of thing and I would love
the final episode to be based around the
destiny you know I have this idea about
like you know some maybe story happening
but in the background you can see
through a window it's like the shipyard
rather than building the destiny I think
that would be pretty cool
um or them discovering the god radio
signal in the first place and then them
deciding to build a destiny something
like that that'll be cool but anyway the
story idea though that Harris came up
with our young American was absolutely
brilliant
he basically said I want to see Stargate
SGC see we've even named it for you
Amazon for the love of God are we doing
everything here let's put a logo
together so they really have no excuse
the United States is not in the business
of interfering in other people's affairs
[Music]
since when sir since this Administration
was elected oh by the way if you do like
the content please consider hitting the
join button and becoming a fully fledged
side tracker you can also go to
signdashtrack.com and pick marvelous
merchandise all of these little things
really help the channel also if you're
new to the channel like subscribe hit
that Bell notification and share the
video wherever the hell you want so the
premise and the basis of the show would
be around that it would be around the
Stargate command which obviously
wouldn't be at Cheyenne Mountain anymore
the gate probably would have been moved
somewhere more public
I always loved nsg1 in particular the
political episodes you know the ones
where Kinsey came in or Woolsey was
involved these such things what are you
talking about I have desperately tried
to maintain some proper control and
accountability but the oversight in
place is completely inadequate the
military
specifically the Personnel directly
involved in the SGC need to be replaced
immediately now
I have several recommendations regarding
wow Bob hold on here Mr President
why do you think I was ordered to keep
quiet
this was a deliberate attempt by the
military and the previous administration
to drive a wedge between us because they
knew I was going to come after them
we need to stick together on this
for God's sakes Bob think of magnitude
of this
for God's sake
is right oh come on Bob the president
filler episode is one of the best sg1
episodes it was definitely it's probably
one of the best Filler episodes actually
ever made because it's not really a
filler episode you know it had lots of
clips from the previous couple of
Seasons where the president was reading
all these documents as reports as on his
inauguration day I've already had my top
secret briefing yes Mr President but not
this
Mr President for the past seven years
the United States Air Force has been
sending teams to other planets by means
of a alien device known as the Stargate
that's funny
um but it was still you know actually a
really good episode
um but I love those sorts of efforts
from Stargate there's one of the reasons
why I love Stargate so much because it
was I did have one foot in reality and
let's be honest politicians would screw
around with this project as much as
possible you know they would want to get
involved they would think they knew
better than the actual teams going
through the gate the the really nice
thing about this idea though of this
Stargate SGC is that you could have a
different story every week you could go
aboard the new BC 305 like I suggested
you could follow different teams you
could have lots and lots of special
guest appearances which would be very
cool actors that maybe aren't regulars
but could come and go you can have lots
and lots of different stories on
different worlds you can see lots of
different parts of the universe that was
been building up for example we could
have a couple of Jaffer episodes we
could have episodes where they're
negotiating with a Lucian Alliance or
something like that you can have it
almost like a political thriller at
times but still have the action
adventure and the big sci-fi
there are lots of ways you could go with
this story and because you're not having
any one overarching story you do
sidestep some of the problems Stargate
has
Stargate coming back actually isn't that
easy because of how advanced the SGC got
in the end we have loads of Starships we
have loads of Technology you know it
would be impossible for the Stargate to
now be a secret so I was always worried
that when Stargate comes back it would
be more like Star Trek than Stargate
but this way of doing it really allows
you to completely sidestep that mind
because you don't have to focus in on
any one story for any length of time it
also would fit in the way I am
absolutely certain Amazon want to do
this series and one because it's been
I've been told that's what they want to
do but also because it's what every TV
show is now and it would be in the
format of 10 maybe 12 episodes
um maybe running two or three different
seasons a year but every season could be
SGC then something you know SGC colon
Jaffa SGC colon BC 305 SGC Cola
something else so similarly like how
Mandalorian or the Boba Fett those
stories that intertwine with each other
and they're almost like chapters out of
a book you could completely do that with
Stargate you could have SGC as the
center and the spine of the story the
center of the novel but have all these
different chapters in and around it so
everything links back to the command but
you can tell completely different
stories every single week now
I'm kind of really excited by this idea
and I really really hope Amazon are
listening
um I do know a couple of people working
in around Amazon and I'm going to be
telling them about this
um not that any of it will get back to
the executives that actually make any
decisions though
but I would love to know exactly what
you think about this idea and what ideas
do you have for Stargate to return
Please get in the comments and make
those messages as long as you damn like
tell me exactly how you want Stargate to
return
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out also
if you enjoy the content please remember
to hit that join button because that
really helps us out as always guys
please stay safe and I'll see you next
time
foreign
[Music]